hey Sam hey nice to have you back thank
you good to do that so the album is
ready to go
is there any backing out at this point
was there point that you thought you
weren't gonna do another album
I need like a big break but was there a
point that no I don't think I ever
thought about not ever doing another
album when and what that album would be
like and you know where I was I was
gonna come about right right right in
the songs that those things were
questions all right right now but no I
always wanted to make into the record
yeah
now why call it suicide it's just I
don't know sort of a stream of
consciousness way I said it started just
writing down titles and I just write
wrote a list of just the things that
just thought about the record thought
about the music thought about where I'm
from and people who've influenced my
songs music that's influenced my songs
and all these things I just saw right
now worse and there's songs in South
Side just kept standing out it that I
had a lyric and body like a back road
the first line of the song says got a
girl yeah but uh South Side's just as
always they didn't kind of know we're
from the south side the person from the
south side right and so does that
represent the album in a way like a
little yeah south side I feel like South
Side is is it's it's cut it's it can be
rural it can be urban and it is sort of
reflects both of those both of those
worlds we're not come from a place where
those worlds just lay on top of it right
yeah and I existed in both yeah so so
kinfolks first song back why did you
choose that song to be your
reintroduction yeah well when you hear
the record you'll you'll hear that there
are some songs that are more
stripped-down some songs are more
produced like a kinfolks but when you
think about you know when I thought
about just our fan base and songs that
have done well in the live show and and
songs that people like to hear on the
radio you know you don't want to hear
there are songs on the record that that
I hope people will like but I think
they'll understand why I wouldn't put
them out his singles on the radio right
but this song kinfolks just was just a
little fun light-hearted song that
doesn't stray too far from what I've
done in the past right and seem to work
is the first first single yeah I love
hard to forget
Thanks so you got the sample of the Webb
Pierce song from 1953 I think is that
yeah you're right that's the year no
yeah somewhere around there yeah so how
did that come about to use that song
well my interest in that era of country
came from I've always been interested in
country music its history the evolution
of it and how it has changed over the
years and evolved but there's a
documentary you know the documentary I
don't know if you've heard or seen it
but I heard of it or seen it but the
documentary that Ken Burns put out takes
sort of takes you through the history of
country more right like Jana
he starts maybe in the 20s and goes up
to maybe 1985 but I just got back on
that old country kick yeah watching that
documentary and a buddy of mine who I
work with Luke Laird he had I've tried
the sample songs in the past and they
just have this thing to work I haven't
found the right song and he played me
this track one day and he where he had
sampled this song over this groove and
as soon as I heard it I was like that's
the one yeah that's the one we got a
ride - do you think music or country
music has changed since your last album
cuz like a five and a half years right
so yeah it's changed yeah it's it's
changed I mean there are there are new
artists that have come along and that
are doing different things it has you
know a lot of ways it's the same as it's
changed some but I mean it I don't think
there are any big trend shifts I think
that just happened to be artists who do
certain things who have come along and
they're good at it and gotten popular
and so I think he just it'll sway this
way but I think the sinner will always
evolve and I think the sinner has
continued to kind of push forward and
and then but we may may be swinging back
towards a country or sound yeah yeah now
obviously kinfolks has been a huge hit
did you have any worries that taking
such a long break the audience wasn't
going to be there anymore yeah I
wondered if you
is anybody interested in hearing a song
for me but you know I wonder that every
time I put out a song I'll always wonder
that yeah and I guess what I'm saying is
I've never taken for granted that people
are interested in my music and and that
song was you know it's pretty isn't it's
I like to be adventurous with songs and
that one is kind of down the middle
right so I think people I was worried
that people expect me to be a little
more radical than that song is and I
didn't want to let them down and they
went with me on it yeah
how are you judge success of this album
put it out yeah so I'm excited about
that and but through buttoning down and
finishing this record out and Emmas
focusing as inspired and motivated
because I have been in a while and I'm
really looking forward to continuing to
write and put out put out you know
whatever comes next
yeah I know a lot of people are excited
for the tour that's coming up I hope so
yeah we're gonna hit the road and and on
this tour and as the bigger tours we've
done the biggest tour we've done I guess
was in 2018 2k15 in a 30 tour and we're
hoping this one will rival that one
these venues were playing you know still
you know as I've been doing this five
six years now and you know I didn't
imagine to be well I didn't imagine that
I would be playing these he's at that
size yeah it's my career but or as soon
as 2018 and even now you know so
hopefully people will come out and we'll
have a good time we're gonna try to keep
stepping it up and adding more songs to
the mix and and just uh and hopefully
we're a little more refined now how do
you pace yourself in the tour life
because it is a grind like obviously
it's amazing to show your fans but it is
it crying right it is yeah but I think
if you try to do too much you know I in
the past I think I tried to do a little
too much and not maybe lighten the load
just a touch but really appreciate the
shows that you are playing instead of
doing a you know 200 shows a year which
is what we did the first couple years
we're
doing maybe 50 shoves this year and
through May and September so you get a
little rest early in the spring and then
you hit it hard and you're ready to roll
about the time you might start getting a
little fatigued you know you're off the
road yeah you hit it you don't speed in
the summer need some downtime yeah you
gotta recharge now do you remember when
you're coming up in music first getting
started did you have like side jobs that
you did in order to pay the bills yeah I
work for a moving company for a while
that was rough I parked cars at a
hospital for a while yeah I got a
Nashville fee but luckily I was able to
get a publishing deal and write songs
I'm simple to write songs on a very got
paid very very little so I was below the
poverty line for a few years but I was
at least able to write songs every day
right and I didn't need much
so I was I was happy yeah we're off
right off the mean strip of Nashville
Broadway Avenue we're really there's
hundreds of people performing every
single day like trying to get their big
break what kind of advice would you have
for those people that are in that grind
trying to hmm get noticed I I hesitate
to give people too much advice because
honestly early on when I was starting
out I think I listen to people too much
and I think their advice was based on
their experience but and every
experience is unique to that person and
their you know their circumstances and
but I mean if there was one one thing
staying true to yourself and not not
take too much advice I guess that might
be the best way to put congratulations
on your music it's very nice to have you
back appreciate it thanks thank you man